I was asking you the question Hans so
great
that's not what I was asking I just want
to know if he had an epiphany moment
shut up you don't need to make fun of my
grammar okay
for all the people in the last live
stream that hated David centofante oh
good news that [ __ ] fat piece of [ __ ]
is gone what a black hole for [ __ ]
chicken alfredo he was gobble gobble
gobble gobble oh
I could sing
what here let's put down a [ __ ]
settlement for you David where's
is it my turn okay
one of your longest road piece anymore
cool
yeah
that sucks
don't puke
what are you drinking over there I'm
gonna puke dude I'm just coughing I took
one shot that's all there was left
one dude one played for that one dude
we give a [ __ ] about that one dude well
I'm happy for that one guy
he was like a good podcast
[Laughter]
no I meant that I love you I'm saying
that
I love the game at the time okay this is
what I'm here for
[ __ ] is this
shut up dude
the [ __ ] is this man
[Music]
[Music]
dude
yeah you're falling apart I'm fine dude
no
I've been working out is what the
problem is oh yeah that's always the
problem with respiratory
issuescular activity
well my plugs are usually just used a
pack of cigarettes within a three day of
spin
so
they're like oh what's all this fresh
air all of a sudden
I like that
also I'm fat as hell
you know you're going twice right nope I
didn't know it makes it way better
foreign
I'm from Houston
that's the only reason I like the
asteroids
you both
no dude [ __ ] you dude I swear to God
that dude what is the matter with you
man
you're trying to [ __ ] with me and I'm
gonna [ __ ] with you I'm not [ __ ] with
you
I wasn't [ __ ] with you I placed here
I mean you don't have any sheep but and
your road is pointing nowhere but yeah
easy win
no but so nobody cares about baseball is
the thing okay Hans that's a fact I'll
tell you that right now
most people don't know I only get
two oh yes resources what are you doing
dude no not that one you can keep that
one uh no so nobody gives a [ __ ] about
baseball in the United States the Astros
uh like the whole thing with the World
Series is it was going up against
college football and that beat it in
ratings it's nuts it's the World Series
and everybody hates the Astros is the
problem
because it seems like they haven't been
a real baseball town and they recently
started getting into it no no the
Houston's always been a big we've always
supported the Astros
s don't ever think that
everybody in Houston's a huge Astros fan
what are they doing this whole time
I mean I'm a huge Astro said I would
that place would sell out when we lost
100 games
so oh it's good then very true baseball
town and they deserve the win they can
support forever
six no yeah no exactly it's like a good
thing that it happened uh that we won
it's given me so much joy in my life
personally uh but on top of that what
gives me much more joy is that the
Yankees hate us so we got the sweet thin
this here and win the World Series that
was the cherry on top I hate the Yankees
Doug uh Stanhope has it really is one of
my favorite jokes
your favorite bits dude yeah it is it is
because it's better it's he goes uh
being a Yankees fan is like [ __ ]
going to a casino and betting on the
house and I'm a horrible Gambler and uh
it's just it hits on a lot of levels
it's very true
they can buy any of their players the
Yankees
that's the advantage in baseball
yes 100
especially a lot of it we don't do that
especially with my boy Dawn
stick with the six we'll stick with the
six dude it counts even if no one has it
so go on
foreign
crazy
wild wacky swaggy every time I uh every
time I'm out in uh comedy hang having
fun with all the comics in the scene
I always think man statistically one of
us is gonna die this year dude and I
always try to guess like I wonder who
it's gonna be no man he came into the
scene and I was like oh well you spoiled
it who wants to trade Keith right you
don't know Keith bro is that it's
special what are you talking about hey
do you want to trade what do you have I
want a sheep you want a sheep yes what
do you have
uh or and I have wood
where and what will you give me one or
and one water for one sheep
wreck you know I don't even remember
what I wanted the extra sheet for so why
not you know what yeah
why why not I'm gonna trade him
I settle I settle for uh you know life
are we still watching again yeah
yeah nine people what's up guys we're
[ __ ] back 11 people what the [ __ ]
Gareth are you done dude pull out your
dick pull out your dick Patrick you
won't dude we got 11 people here if
somebody puts down ten dollars Patrick
will put his dick you gotta wait for
those people to respond what time is it
what what wait wait wait is it my turn
I'll ruin you roll the nine
Sate
Sate eight eight oh give me that sheep
who wants brick
I'll break you
who wants Rock
nobody
nobody wants to see how to do it
okay
um
nine nine oh
let's go let's go it's your turn you
know what you said
I have three eight six
I gotta build some roads fast two does
anybody have a two no no okay cool
[ __ ] you nine
no no two doesn't count
are you done
yeah so what do you think
global warming no
uh
the Q nightclub shooting
oh god oh Colorado yeah best shootings
in America
they could adversize themselves as the
best shootings in America nine again
I just think it's like just constant
stoking the base eight with rhetoric
no it's just called you're gonna get
politicians using gay people as pawns
and just like be like the I took a
text I took a class in college in this
it was for
um
I thought I can't remember what the
subject is right now but this [ __ ]
bit it was like speech or something like
that and uh this girl seven this girl uh
ended up like talking about how like
every
school shooter was a male
and like that was like one of she was a
substitute teacher all than males but
just attacking the gender of the problem
is not going to provide a solution no
that's true but that's what school
shooter no no no you're correct yes
we're talking about gender no but that
was that was yeah that's what the whole
presentation boiled down to is what I'm
telling you so um
yeah not like what causes a school
shooter just he was white or [ __ ] a
male yeah he was a man he did no no it
wasn't about right it typically no it's
like it's like 93 percent
it's like well it's not about white
males it happens oh hell yeah dude give
me that
well done just that
not like me
six
he would roll a six
so what do you think three full
shootings in America
man who [ __ ] knows that's a crazy
question it really is like
because I just don't like each other you
know like when you're driving and you
just flip someone off or someone flips
you off it's like the general Vibe of
this place right we're not very happy
with each other so it's like if they're
not human it's easier to shoot them
which is also weird because it's like in
traffic like in a situation like that
where you're far away and separated for
some from someone like the internet as
well it's easy to be like [ __ ] you I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care but when
you're [ __ ] in a room like yeah
in a small apartment and immediately you
get begin to like get annoyed by them
and hate them and hate what they do and
like they can like sit there clipping
their fingernails or something and you'd
be like [ __ ] I [ __ ] stand this person
so then you're like guys get in a fight
so it's like where is the [ __ ] medium
ground if you're too close to somebody
hate them but if you're far away from
them you still hate them
so I agree with that I think yeah I
think humans just naturally [ __ ] hate
each other and it's I mean we all fight
over land because we're very much like
no we're exclusive I want to be here
alone
Keith Keith
um or like there's people in general uh
like exclusivity is something that comes
up in general throughout I think
everywhere in society it's what human
existence is about exclusivity and uh
yeah of course it's our mom but yeah
we're supposed to do a drinking game
I already have one oh I'm sorry from you
okay
foreign
what were you saying girl oh humans are
all about exclusivity like you want to
make clicks you four groups and stuff
like that what I've liked about Austin
comedy so far as people have just been
like hey you know what we're all [ __ ]
you know for the most part okay with one
of another
um you know and new people show up and
you can be like hey what's going on man
where are you from I met all of you
[ __ ] you all came to my city
like that's just what's happened like
I'm totally for that and I think well I
think like no just accepting anyone and
everyone is what's most important like
understanding the medium understanding
hey they might have a shitty night
whatever you're going to bomb if you're
having fun or doing whatever you're
going to do
that's cool but it's just about living
[ __ ] life dude
killing it would you get a five did you
get a five yeah
[ __ ] does anybody have a wood
no
come on
come on you ain't got no wood uh you
don't got a wood no oh nobody has wood
foreign
I see
yeah there's only two of us here eight
oh yeah give me that sheep be [ __ ] off
oh that's good for me dude no you're
both heavily benefit from me I don't
trade these two sheep that I just got in
for one here and turn on this brick and
then I'm gonna build a road
get out of this [ __ ]
going to foreign lands
coming for you
Hans what do you think about Alec
Baldwin shooting that one and that was
I'm like a 1G dude it's funny I kind of
hate you guys attacking each other
because it makes me
no no no
I'm not getting any wood
it's a [ __ ] up board you can't attack
nobody you have to attack Hans dude I
have no cards I have zero cards
oh she were both on [ __ ] eight
you're gonna have to choose no you gotta
I have no cards you get nothing from me
yeah
[ __ ] you oh you have no cards well then
I have to take
them that was my whole point
well then I but I wanted to attack
so you if I had questions
how many cards do you have
I had
five and now I have six it doesn't look
like five times seven I had six now I
have seven all right now you're lying to
me about card numbers why don't you
pulling out four five six seven okay six
I stole one for once all right calm so
down where do you think the uh internet
oh I see we tied dude we're gonna be
like have you ever seen that Futurama
happen with the net neutrality [ __ ] you
remember that [ __ ] back in like 2014 oh
nobody cares about our rights and then
we're gonna like
we've we've all been brainwashed by
Propaganda yeah nothing ever happened no
that's right no it did
no it did that's why you're here you
know this thing called inflation that's
happened right now you know the whole
thing everybody's worried about
inflation really what's happening is
that's just corporate greed so like the
corporate like most corporations
they're making record profit they're
Drive they're they're saying oh this is
inflation but really what's happening is
is they're lowering the amount of [ __ ]
that they're selling you and then
they're also increasing the price you're
not gonna work for us we're going to
take more money from you that's a
hundred percent what's happening
that's what's exactly happening
that's exactly what's happening a
hundred percent yeah
we're probably gonna all get killed for
saying this right now too 100
the businesses look after each other
eight
it's sweet
for you at least two for one hey can I
can see clearly now the sun is gone
done
what do you think about
David centifonte eight
oh that was just something that he said
there's meme he said something mean to
me before he was
he says something meme he said something
mean to me or it's because something
that you said he clearly joking around
you know what you know what oh David
said something
funny everyone funny idiot he wants
bread hey David I'm shut up Patrick [ __ ]
you
hey David you suck dick
I don't need to I have two I have one
[ __ ] card
for what what are we here one card no
whatever your one card is
oh
what is it
I hate you so much
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] you five five five
[ __ ] you Patrick I hate you
just dick ass for me dude
here you go Hans
no I uh
you know I'd love to talk about politics
or religion or something but
you haven't seen Andor yet dude go it's
the best thing I've ever seen from Star
Wars other than episode five and six
from your last offer have you watched
and or Patrick
just in case you were have you watched
Andor
what's that on Disney oh you don't even
know what I'm talking about so did you
ever watch Rogue one
no
way Rogue one yeah Star Wars you hated
it
you hated Rogue one wait a minute why
did you hate Rogue one it was boring it
was [ __ ] boring go re-watch that go
away this character dying on the planet
when it blew up and he stopped no I did
something they were running and he
stopped and they were like why are you
stopping and he was like no reason at
all
and then they sailed off and they're
like ah you wanted to be one with the
four three hero and it was like what
man to this day I'm like what the [ __ ]
so you do that this movie you watched
the [ __ ] out of this movie it was
because it was a prequel and he was like
that was a good movie
blown up at the end that was sick yeah
the end was good it was a good movie all
the way through
dude the blind [ __ ] Samurai dude
that was like I am home with the force
the force is one with me I am one with
the force the force is one with me I am
one with the force this was just Star
Wars pretty cool it was it was the best
Star Wars movie period like out of all
of the new movies that they made too I
got a seven and door
and door's about
it
thanks
sorry Android
is about uh Cassie and Andor he was the
other main character in that movie other
than the girl
so
um it's really good dude when did that
come out it's coming out recently the
10. yeah the the finale is coming out on
Wednesday and it's incredible like the
whole show is really good there's no way
you would say it's boring I've watched
pretty much all of it but also I'm a
huge star horse nerd so it's kind of
different Hans are you a Star Wars nerd
yeah that's Star Wars how do you feel
about Star Trek too what do you think
about [ __ ] uh Rogue one
nothing
no
um
for me like everything that star voices
made is [ __ ] other than Rogue one
and this other thing and of course did
you watch the Clone Wars
too powerful
have you watched the Clone Wars before
Hans no
uh does a bunch of voice acting
um [ __ ] Seth Green it's highly
unrealistic why would you need like
pistols and like people walking around
and said I get that
well that's what made and or this no
shoe or this new show and shoe this new
Show's uh this new show so cool is like
they kind of expand like the pistols are
slower than bullets yeah
no you have the force bro
the force guides it into the lightsaber
no the force it's slower than a tracer
the force guides it into the dude you
don't understand the four songs it's
been explained in the morning
I should try it [ __ ]
[Music]
no way not at all seven hard enough
you know what I bet you would get hard
you gay boy
um let's see how can I [ __ ] over Patrick
the most
oh you really don't want to yeah I don't
care you [ __ ]
yeah thanks dude I'll tell you one
absolutely I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
that's how I feel about that
why'd you have to do that to me that
last game dude
you literally just shoot me out of the
water that last game
ten oh I got nothing
I've got nothing for nobody
this game just belongs to Hans what the
[ __ ] he has the power of 11 fans
11 fans 11 fans watching and going
please wins where's it where are they
fueled by them nobody's in the chat
I don't know it's [ __ ] uh five
oh you sons of [ __ ] you [ __ ] hey
guys sorry the trout what's [ __ ] up
how's it going
what
what'd you say I got a five he's mad
you put a [ __ ] Knight on my five you
dick
oh yeah the good reason is you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] why'd you have to
do me like that in that last game every
single every single no it seemed like
you were playing the game specifically
to [ __ ] me in my ass
because I got the longest road at the
end because you didn't append to his
Road he went on a different direction
appendages five
oh my God
you're losing play to win [ __ ] I don't
care no I don't care no no no no no no
no no no at this point I don't care dude
oh yeah Jimmy Hart no I still have a
chance as long as I can [ __ ] you I'm
fine dude that makes me happy as long as
I can [ __ ] you I'm fine
[Laughter]
that's okay dude you saw exact stick and
Dylan stick dude we were so drunk the
other night apparently flipped off like
a bunch of people and Christmas and like
yeah and Chris was like in one of the
cars like behind like a Roa cars and we
were in the middle of Sixth Street when
we were leaving where were we we got
hammered before we went over to my
apartment that night yeah I remember
anything like where we went after the
creek of the cave I don't even remember
the night you're talking about yeah dude
we were drunk as hell
[Music]
[Music]
six oh it's so close to five oh
I've been so funny and hilarious if I
got a five dude I've been so fine
nope roomba's ready
okay so yeah do you have a Roomba yeah I
do
why I love it it keeps my house clean
why wouldn't I want it
because you can just do it yourself you
know I do still
yeah you have to for a good clean at
least once a week
the problem with my Roomba is it's not
that smart
the problem with my Roomba is that it's
not smart and it like gets caught under
[ __ ] and stuff oh my God but it gets
under my bed that I would never do
myself exactly that's where it comes in
handy 100 it does it every day yes yes
you don't have to think about it I'll
turn mine on two or three times in a day
I can just use the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] I like was just watching it
think and walk or go around like bumped
into things
mine doesn't think it just gets it just
keeps bumping into it and then it'll
turn around or it'll get caught on some
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes dude that's so cool oh I was so
hoping for five foot Eight's good for me
too it doesn't help me at all it helps
both of you yeah I know it's great it's
[ __ ] fantastic
[ __ ] you know it's so funny I'm gonna
use those two sheep for the
build Road over here Panda Express was
open right now I would totally go try oh
[ __ ] better Express up tomorrow if it's
in the airport it's at the [ __ ]
Austin Airport oh no no go to the Salt
Lick at the Austin Airport that's where
you're going yeah go because you'll get
brisk you can get a brisket sandwich
there for like 15 bucks worth it I think
they have a Whataburger 15. nice it's a
big brisket sandwich it's worth it it's
the best thing by far
I don't even care about that [ __ ]
sheep
three shut up ons with your Cockiness
right now
oh yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I haven't seen you in a month I was
happy to see you I'm not even that's
[ __ ] insane
I don't care [ __ ] you
yeah dude yes this is Gary's Revenge
this is what you get dude
oh my God if it was I had I'm doing it
well my God look at it
I'm killing myself
no you [ __ ] suck dude I had to
[ __ ] hey
it's ain't this game man God damn why
did I agree to stay and play another
game I wanted to do I was like let's
stay and play another game guys come on
it'll be fun [ __ ] regretting that now
God damn
three four nine
he's at a port yeah I think Hans has got
a really good grip on this right now
no I mean I'm gonna have a fighting
chance here in a moment
what in your
room one two three four five six seven
eight nine he has nine you're kidding me
you're kidding me that's the most hey
before before
you end it just make sure I have five
points because I had a victory point
also yeah okay cool but uh did Patrick
get dead last I had three which is good
good wow no that's horrible you suck
dude yeah
[Music]
three not bad
gosh darn it dang it that was a good
quick game like you know like
I'm fine if you won and after you did
that to me with the last game like why
the [ __ ] did you do that you gave it to
Hans you [ __ ] I don't care silence
both times you fed Hans the wind did he
get to win the game before that
[Music]
it's all about
you have problems with your mom what is
she dead or something what the [ __ ]
whoa I think in reality Hans is the
enemy here and we're he Mind Trick
turned us on each other but in reality
we didn't really get a screen I'm still
stronger than both of us together we
have a chance
two games two games in a row
nah I'm fine with it when do you think
your fans are gonna find out that these
games are scripted and that you and we
let you win no that's the only thing
that's gonna happen we should do like a
Nathan for you where are we all recreate
one of these podcasts you know we
memorize the lines and then someone has
to play Garrett and they're like oh my
God
that page is just my life this is
like Bigfoot and like the astross
what look dude you gotta live a little
all right Hans that's what I'm saying
dude you live a lot I live a ton you
live a lot you
live
great you gotta Live Well it's every you
know how like you know how like
sometimes normal people will say well I
don't mean to say normal people but uh
lucky people tend to say I wish I was
[ __ ] for the benefits you're like a
regular person who just so happens to be
[ __ ] enough for the benefits yes
I fall in a very specific Gap cool
enough you're like a comfortable I feel
like comfortably [ __ ] in social
situations so nobody questions it but
you're normal enough that you can work a
job and drive a car
you know what I mean yeah
and do well at my job yeah exactly and
get people hired so you're agreeing with
me yeah you're [ __ ] in a way that we
don't knock you from being bad at comedy
also
whoa
whoa I'm not bad at comedy okay I'm
getting much better okay
that was just [ __ ] around if I'm
doing just [ __ ] I could just come
out here I could do jokes dude that's
just Tuesday two jokes
yeah you you hurt my feelings dude I
have a lot of confidence issues with
this how do you feel about that dude how
do you feel about that dude I didn't
mean to attack you how do you feel about
that such a sensitive spot I had a crowd
that was virtual and I chose to go with
their side yeah you attacked me do you
think like maybe like put a lot of ego
into your comedy no I don't have any
kind of thing
I don't have anything no yeah I agree
with that I don't think I really don't
know I really don't talk about myself or
I really don't give a [ __ ] about I know
a lot of people with one of those
I know a lot of people who have an ego
in the scene who
who not a lot but I know a couple of
people who have an ego that Gareth
couldn't pass realistically I don't care
more like a funny and like if you try
hard at comedy then it's not funny
what do you mean I'm trying to learn
they're like so
I'm scared that like tacos
and then it's like you're just like
remembering the lines and trying to hunt
your emotions and like
trying to like do it technically correct
but you're not actually just up there
just being a goofball right [ __ ]
around no I agree
yeah I've been lately trying to
just [ __ ] around more often instead of
because when yeah when you when you
listen to yourself back when you're very
written out you're you can recognize it
and you're like man I wish I was just
more lucid and just yeah and then you're
just yelling at the audience and the
audience is just like whoa well you
notice that when you do small shows
when you're re when you're right now in
the theater or whatever the [ __ ] and
you're doing like Arenas but yes yeah
Arenas theaters Vulcan whatever when
you're doing that it's easier to be
written down in very like half them with
you yeah but when you're doing like a
small random bar show it's like why are
you talking like this yeah exactly
person they kind of give you that like
they they let you know what their
expression that they're like yeah
it's more like a it's like a close hand
magic or like when you go into public
and do magic yeah it's not like you're
on a stage and it's like and now
everyone will shut up and listen yeah be
transported to another Realm
all right thank you for tuning in oh
yeah this time we mean it